I
was born in Los Angeles. In a
house in a canyon,
that was in a nest of palm trees
that casted these thin, unmoving shadows
like prison bars.
It was very California Gothic.
I am very California Gothic. I am
the child
of those people that you used to see in the ads for cigarettes in
the back of Life magazine. Those
handsome people that were always wearing
terry cloth robes and penny loafers, smoking cigarettes,
looking like they just heard the funniest joke of their
life. The Marlboro Man
met the Virginia Slims woman and had
me.
It's very California Gothic to have your best friend's
mother who is a movie star keep her cracked Oscar in
the kitchen next to the salt and the cumin and the Coumadin.
(laughter)
It's very California Gothic to see Joan Didion crying at the wheel of
her green Jaguar on ?Moore?
Park below
Ventura. It's very California Gothic to have a
cousin who is a rock star. My cousin is Chuck
Negron, the lead singer for the group Three Dog
Night. And he bore a startling resemblance
to Charles
Manson. Now, when
you were a kid like me in 1970, growing up in Los Angeles, you
knew that you shared the city with Charles
Manson and his
family, because that grisly murderous night of mayhem
and Helter Skelter was all anybody could talk
about. And for those of you who are too young to know what Helter Skelter is,
it's kind of like twerking -- but with
blood.  And it was really
scary. Really horrifying.
And, and my
parents -- they were always going out on the town. They were always
getting dressed up and leaving like in Mad Men, right? They
just left me alone, they just went
out.  One night my father came in and he
said, "I want you to close all these doors and windows. I don't want
these hippies to come in here and de-gut you."
(laughter)
You heard him.  That was an option, in
my childhood, to be de-gutted.
And it left a tremendous psychic
scar on my life.
It has stayed with me forever and I'm still very disturbed by
hippies and longhairs
and headbands and large candles and
beads and bandanas. I just don't like any
of it. But, um,
I was only twelve years old.  I was a tween, I was a
changeling. I was changing into a man.
But childhood is a place where your fears
are disproportionate. They're huge.  But then so are
your goals.  And, and that's where the magic can happen, in
these goals. And my goal when I was a child was to
own a
gorilla.  Or, you know
a monkey or an ape.  Anything from the monkey, ape, gorilla family. I just wanted someone to, uh,
you know, be able to play hide and go
seek with. Swim,
shoot
dice, light ironing.
And my parents were these really emphatic kind of ghetto people from New York City, right, who
didn't like animals at all.  And my mother
said, "Look.  You will
never, ever see a monkey walk through that
door."
But something very magical happened
that
Christmas of 1970.  You see, my uncle Ishmael -- that was his real name,
Ishmael. He was a trucker and he
had his own flatbed truck.
Which meant that he could follow other people around who had flat bed trucks and pick up what
fell off of theirs.
And
one day, he was closing down this raggedy-ass Circus Vargas in the Hollywood Bowl parking
lot on the
Highland, and he came across a monkey that somebody was throwing out.
A live monkey,
named Carroll. To Rs two Ls.
And we knew it was called Carroll because it had its own cage with its name on
it and that is what changed the deal with my parents because they
are emphatic New Yorkers, so they
said, "Well, if it's
free . . . and it comes
with a cage, what harm can it do?"
Well.  Carroll came
to the house. I was so excited. Carroll arrived on that flatbed truck on a pile
of
grapefruits, in his cage. And when I went out there and greeted him
and I looked into those big round eyes, I knew that that I would understand
everything that monkey had to say to me. And that I would
experience
unconditional love. Well. The monkey promptly
squatted, s##t into its hand, and then threw it into my eye.
Under-paw.
(laughter)
And from the shadow, I heard the ice clink in my mom's drink.
And she said,  "That's your monkey."
(laughter)
I loved my monkey so much, and I stuck with my
monkey while everybody turned against my
monkey. Sometimes they even put a sheet over its cage. I stuck
with my monkey when my monkey
willfully and intentionally f###ed my grandmother's mink hat, and
I took the blame.
(laughter)
Carroll
was my most cherished early Christmas present.
But Carroll was not the only unexpected visitor that
season.  One Christmas night, the Santa Ana
winds blew too hard against the glass in
cold frightening Los
Angeles. I had fallen asleep into a deep Christmas sleep. And I
looked out the window and I saw a
van pull up in front of the house, turn off and just stop.
Nothing happened. For thirty minutes. Nothing happened.
And I thought to myself, this is
it. This is my nightmare, it's going to come true.
And I thought to myself well at least I made it to
twelve. Then
I looked out and the door opened up and then finally this plume of
smoke rolled out and these hippies came out on
wobbly feet, and started slinking up to the front of
the
house. As the cast of Woodstock
approached
I,
I felt vulnerable in my Charlie Brown sleeping T-shirt.
And I waited for the physical and
emotional attack to
begin. There was a knock on the door.
And I heard my mother's voice, muffled -- I knew she was dead, throat
cut -- I had read the papers. But then
I heard her say, "Grilled cheese sandwiches for everyone."
Why was my mother giving protein to a serial
killer? And then there was a blast as my father came into my room and
he said, "Your cousin Chuck is here.  Come
down." And I timidly followed my father down the stairs
to see in the living room what appeared to be Mama Cass Elliot,
Jim
Morrison, and assorted longhairs devouring
Christmas cookies. My cousin stood shyly holding a
Three Dog Night album at the stereo, and he told us he was going to play a
song for us that no one had
ever heard before. Side One,
Song A.
"Jeremiah was a bullfrog, was a good friend of mine
I never understood a
single word he said but I helped him a-drink-a his wine."
And on that cold, windy night,
everyone stood up and started to dance.
My father grabbed my mother and they started to dance.  I
looked over and Jim Morrison -- "The" Jim Morrison -- was
dancing the jitterbug with my grandmother on the coffee
table. It was so
extraordinary.  It was so magnificent.  The hippies and the longhairs were all singing along
to choruses of "Joy to the world,
All the boys and girls now . . . "
And then, the song was over and someone picked up the needle and put it
back at the beginning. And the song continued, and the
dancing continued. And there's something
emblematic about certain California Christmas memories, and
and here is one that is
transcendent, rock and roll.
And this is what made my monkey
legendary. He came
down -- hurtling, down
the stairs and went right up to the stereo, and started dancing.
(laughter)
Had
we forgotten?  Carroll was
a circus monkey. And this was her cue.
"You know, I love the ladies . . . "
His arms outstretched like rubber bands and he started picking off the ornaments on the
Christmas tree. "Love to have my fun . . . "
The monkey started to juggle.
"I'm a high night
rider, and a rainbow flyer, a
straight shooting sun of a gun.  I said a
straight shooting . . . "   I wish you were all there
to have seen the expression on those stoned --
we found out
later, on
L.S.D. -- hippies and my grandmother, as
Carroll, my monkey, rightfully claimed the spotlight.
"Glee" is a very good word to use, because that's what it was.  Pure happiness
and glee, because I was twelve years old and I was
alive.  And I had escaped Manson's
knife. And I had a monkey with
talent.  And as
everybody
danced, and as everybody laughed, and as everybody ate cookies, I looked at my family,
I looked at these people,
and all of their crimes --
past, present and future -- seemed to just spill out and dissolve into
the contours of the blue shag rug,
and as Carroll balanced an ashtray
on his nose, it was as though I was looking into my future.
Because I
realized all the glorious things that could happen
with music. And with joy. And that Christmas,
the last one that I was ever a child, I learned a very important
lesson that I'd like to pass on to you all tonight. And that's that no
matter how
horrible your day is and no matter how scary your night is,
everything
can turn on a dime, and with a
knock on the door.
Thank you.